yeah this morning tropical storm elsa is
bearing down on eastern new england
it roared past maryland's eastern shore
overnight with wind gusts over 60 miles
an hour
elsa is dumping more rain on new york
city where flash flooding from a
different storm
left streets and subway stations under
water
cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beradelli is tracking
elsa
and another threat created by hot
weather in the west jeff good morning
good morning vlad good morning everybody
so in the new york city area and the
long island area
we've already seen four to six inches of
rain the good news with the system
is it's blazing its way northeast very
quickly but still producing heavy rain
could still see some wind gusts to 70
miles an hour long island
and cape cod as the storm moves out but
it's moving at 31 miles an hour
so it should be about done by the early
afternoon
take a look at the west once again week
after week we are talking about another
heat dome the good news is this one is
further south so it's not over seattle
portland and vancouver but the bad news
is this is an extreme heat wave on top
of what is the worst
drought in modern history look at these
numbers 119
is possible in vegas today watch what
happens overnight tonight it doesn't go
down very much
so there's no relief death valley in the
morning on
sunday morning is going to be 104
degrees and then during the afternoon
130 degrees is possible
redding could also break an all-time
record at 119 degrees
so unfortunately we keep seeing these
heat waves you know week after week
and i can't even say that this is
necessarily the new normal
because it looks like it'll just
continue to get worse
until we stop heating the planet oh jeff
thank you